thank you
[Music]
all right I'm gonna tell you about this
Chinese married couple in Irvine okay
most Chinese married couples in Irvine
kind of are living a pretty decent life
there's uh the woman is a dermatologist
the husband is a radiologist uh doctor
of radiology it's boring us so they're
pretty yeah pretty kind of sounds like
your stereotypical Irvine couple oh it's
like it's the life Chinese and working
in the medical field yeah it's the life
our parents dreamed we would have that's
those are the partners I want to watch
actually oh yeah when you see like
boring people are like what's your [__]
style
it's probably wild you think so yeah
because their lives are boring like
they're the pillowcase [__] swinging
type but what is that
yeah they're making love both of them
both of them
the dude starts noticing he's having
like internal like stomach problems oh
no and he starts to suspect that his
wife is poisoning him oh wow how do you
just suspect yeah
wait a second yeah it's not that you
know three day old Chinese food that you
ate it's your wife is poisoning you
that's your go-to she might like look at
him a certain way you know just to check
if he's how I was feeling well also
they're both doctors so you know you'd
have to take that into account that if
you're feeling a certain way you could
probably just check on that yeah you got
your own deductive reasoning maybe he
already deducted he was like I didn't
eat anything weird and then blah blah
blah he checked those things off and
then he's like it's got to be the why
yeah so so she also does resent me
that's right she does hate my guts he
puts up a hidden camera in his kitchen
to figure out if she's doing something
to his food he finds that she's been
pouring Drano into his teeth oh drain
over
draina would have a distance that's how
bad tea tastes themselves
some loose leaf tea some some wing hot
funky
maybe she was just trying to clear his
because you know Drano really works to
clear the pipes you want to play you
want to play that side yeah because then
if she if he drinks Drano then it clears
up all the hair and all the things just
mind his own business dude she does have
so she was arrested but here's the
interesting part her defense lawyer is
like proposing all of these you know
like reasons why she didn't right yeah
so since you're playing that side oh
they are they're they're admitting find
some sense in this defense okay this is
the number one defense her lawyer saying
no she wasn't trying to kill you there
was an ant problem on the counter and
she put Drano in the T to attract the
ants into the cup
and serve it to him
she didn't mean for him to drink it at
all wait what that's apparently what I
believe her that's what the defense
lawyer is saying that it wasn't meant
for him to drink she would do that
to get the ants to come to the cup and
die in the secret camera is the cup like
10 feet above the ground that's not
supposed to and the guy climbs up oh
that one's for me
put a little like sticky note like don't
drink no it's and she this is a repeated
thing
so he kept ringing it but she's like no
that wasn't for you to drink it was for
the ants to like because they put on the
counter Island the judge needs to be
like nope lawyer you're going to jail
too for stupidity I'm also just like I
feel like in the time that my man's
thought this had a stomachache you know
had this hypothesis went online bought a
secret camera found time to upload the
secret camera check the footage because
he's a doctor go go get a test
I find out that there's some [__]
Drano inside of you yeah get some blood
work done pee in a [__] cup you
probably drank it for four more days and
you had to [__] be drinking this [__]
yeah yeah yeah
it's just a catcher like how to catch
Drano
bro have you opened up a bottle of Drano
there's a very distinction yeah isn't it
blue too yeah it is very jelly yeah yeah
it's like biscuit yeah speaking of like
you know boring couples being freaks
this might just be their like long Kink
play
yeah he's at like the you know the phone
like whatever like visit between the
glass and he's like she's like yeah you
like that
I [__] love that you put Drano in my
teeth again she's like you like what I
[__] sued you and you're going to
jail oh yeah
when I get out of here oh boy okay so
you believe you believe her story hell
no she's I kind of believe it damn well
the thing is she made the tea she left
it there right yeah
but she never told him to drink it
he just comes up and goes oh that's true
wait are ants attracted to Drano it's
like a thing you know I don't even know
I don't know what ancient Chinese secret
she uses because I've never heard of it
usually when you have a home remedy that
gets rid of ants it doesn't involve
another chemical it's like usually like
vinegar right or something yeah and that
smells already weird so you're not gonna
drink it or maybe buy an ant trap
because you guys can afford it and get
Drano you can get raid you can afford
[__] pest control but she's obviously
trying to kill this guy slowly and by
the way I feel like this guy's dumb
they're rich enough to have lawyer so
the person who who was using this
defense is not a public defender that's
a real one that's a legit lawyer come up
with yeah I would have said dude Drano
unclogs clogs and drains it'll unclog
your [__] up the patience
he can't hear [__] in days
Chinese chicks man the guy the guy
apparently sprayed on your teeth he said
he didn't notice it because he likes his
tea hot and the tea was very hot what
dude notice that it was that's not a
thing maybe she's putting like little
bits where it's like undetectable could
he not smell
no he just he's busy I guess he just
like Downs it and gets out the door you
know what I'm scared of I'm scared of
Articles like this because I feel like
right in the mail like all right so
we'll all drink a little bit of his
teeth yeah
and if there's Drano in here
I'm gonna make you guys all do it I am
kind of curious though like you could
snuff it out also she's the worst
murderer ever
enough time to survive to set up a
[__] coup against you like yeah
exactly and also like that's all you
that's probably all they had in the
house so she goes we'll just use it yeah
this might kill somebody have you seen
Drano like I expect more from doctors
yeah yeah Asians
out like do something in your sleep
which is pills or something life to just
get lazy at the end yeah and two like
Poison's a tough one because it's like
they know that if he dies it's gonna
come out in the toxicology there's
better poisons than that and they could
link that to you easily well maybe
that's why they were doing little bits
of Drano or it didn't actually kill them
yeah she wasn't putting enough initially
to kill him that's why he was just
getting you know bad guts yeah he got he
just gets ripped
[Laughter]
hey guys this dude Drano diet that's the
prosecution he just lifts his shirt up
here he's like you're on her guilty
damn
uh but I'll play Devil's Advocate though
like what the [__] did he do to make her
so mad she had to poison him he's a
[__] up guy well Bart says Chinese
girls are crazy so that might be the
first thing so she's just crazy well
okay if this guy can't smell that
there's Drano in his [__] drink I
feel like he's also one of those super
oblivious dudes so you know there's
those dudes where like your chick will
tell you like oh can you not do this or
don't do whatever and he's the one
that's constantly [__] scratching the
car or fumbling the keys or like [__]
[__] up because it's open and maybe
she's just so [__] pissed all the
time yeah
gambled all the money away on crypto or
something yo slots yeah I'm Candy Crush
here we'll just we'll just do a face
judgment what do you think oh she looks
nice yeah killer yeah killer bro and if
she's uh found guilty of this attempted
murder she's gonna get eight years she
has great skin huh eight years because
she's a dermatologist maybe because he
didn't die so it's an attempted murder
yeah right and maybe they could even get
that somehow down yeah so she'll do like
two years if she goes to jail and she
comes out do you think she could still
be a dermatologist no well I feel like
if that happened to me right if I find
that out like I would never call the
cops I would just sit with the Bros like
bro what do I do
look you tried to kill me off like do I
break up with her I'm like [__] I don't
even know like you're back bro
I'm gonna have a date night or a
staycation
I'm surprised his internal organs didn't
burn up yet yeah yeah yeah maybe that's
that's the trick it's like you can't put
so much that he'll detect it so you
gotta find The Sweet Spot because when
you pour Drano down the drain you can
hear that [__] sizzle the hair oh it's
gross but every time he's done drinking
he pours it like oh I wonder what's done
my coffee cup is gone yeah it says that
that's what my acid reflux feels like so
like yeah he's like business as usual
dude what if he was like trying to
trigger because like what if he knew but
she didn't know that he knew so he was
like hey I made you some tea and then he
did it to her oh like why don't you
drink this tea let's share today and
she's like oh no no and then you're like
why not you know and then dude Classic
Game of Thrones style yeah I guess what
it says is that she was taken advantage
of his daily ritual because he's very
like methodical yeah he does the same
thing the doctor so it's like oh hot cup
of tea every morning
puts the thing I guess it's like hot
lemonade that's what it says what the
hell's hotline my Countryside or
whatever I guess hot lemon tea why does
that attract ants that's the thing that
is just a [__] excuse I know it's
just a really really bad defense yeah
dude but as a defense lawyer like what
could you even what's a better defense
than that you're guilty and get as
little years as possible you're like you
got eight years you could you could deal
with that like why do you want to kill
me so bad like insanity you don't even
go to jail you're gonna go to some
[__] my home yeah oh yeah I do want
to know the drama though as to what got
her to this point where she's like I
need to kill this [__]
you know maybe they need to spice it up
maybe their life yeah she's a doctor too
they did that they definitely spice the
[__] up yeah they're on JK news now you
would think she would have access to
more like better elements to use yeah
it's the worst Showtime original series
there's gonna be no docs on this dude
it's like if this was a script you're
like but why did you make them doctors
yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign